soul rock bonjour et bienvenue dans une
europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
bruxelles est réalisée en association
avec tv 78 au sommaire de ce best-of la
précarité des travailleurs européens
avec l'eurodéputée sylvie brunet est
tout de suite la protection des animaux
pendant le transport avec l'eurodéputée
caroline rousse sous une robe sûr
sensation déjà en quelques mots ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler l'objectif de
cette commission d' enquête qui a été
laissé lancée en jeu leur appel en
septembre dernier
oui en fait en septembre on a lancé
cette commission denquête c'était une
demande sont l'ancien mandat à l'origine
des verts l'objectif de cette enquête
justement c'est de pouvoir vérifier les
conditions de transport des animaux
vivants et
d'améliorer le texte s'il existe une
réglementation il ya un règlement 1.285
qui va devoir être revu et
et améliorer remis à l'anti jeu pour
enfants pour cette législation
il ya quelques mois que vous vous êtes
rendu en italie vous étiez en compagnie
des ong de protection animale d'un
vétérinaire et d'autres membres aussi de
la commission donc de cette commission
thomas ouais c'est la présidente tilly
messe de camions ont été contrôlés en
provenance de pologne et de roumanie
une des pays de l'union européenne déjà
expliquez moi comment est-ce que vous
procédez comment est ce que vous avez
repéré ces camions alors en fait on a
été invité par justement les ong pour
constater avec eux les conditions de
transport c'était pour la période de
pâques puisque on a regardé les
transports d'agneau et de moutons ils
ont des points stratégiques ans mais au
bord de l'autoroute pour
voire des passages des camions en suis
né camion on regarde s'il ya des
infractions visuellement déjà et ensuite
elles sont une procédure qui est
appliquée le rapport de ces camions vous
avez retrouvé des moutons des agneaux
par centaines dans quelles conditions
est ce que vous avez pu constater qu'ils
allaient ont été transportées alors en
fait sur ces camions alors sur le
premier camion par exemple on avait une
attraction sur le temps de transport
le premier camion avait 35 heures de
transport sans s'arrêter sur l'autre
camion il y avait des tétines da
breuvage pour les animaux qui n'étaient
pas adaptés ils étaient adaptés aux
cochons et non pas aux agneaux et
moutons on a vu des animaux qui était
nonce au vrai et puis sur la
réglementation un point 2005
il faut que l'animal puisse rester dans
une position naturelle c'est-à-dire deux
bouts et qu'il est un espace suffisant
sur la tête pour pouvoir bouger et ce
n'était pas le cas alors finalement ces
deux camions ils ont pu être arrêtés
pour une inspection alors comment cette
dernière ces procès s'est déroulé
comment est ce que vous l'avez signalé
voilà la place de dieu en fait comme je
disais donc les ong nous ont appelés ils
ont un certain nombre d'informations
donc on se met son bord d'autoroute avec
eux sur des parkings quand le camion
passe mais ensuite camion à plusieurs
voitures quand on voit qu'il ya une
infraction dans appelle les services de
police qui sont prévenus déjà en amont
j'avoue que la police italienne elle a
été assez réactive à ce niveau là alors
on a un problème c'est un problème
géographique c'est à dire que dès qu'on
suit aimions si ça fait pas partie du
secteur de la première police qu'on a
appelés il faut qu'on continue à suivre
le camion donc ça peut durer
honteuse heures à suivre le camion la
police à rim se met sur le côté de
l'autoroute double le camion et fait
arrêter le camion à la sortie d'une aire
d'autoroute et on commence inspection
ensuite pour l'un des camions celui qui
était en provenance de roumanie vous
avez trouvez donc à son bord 600 moutons
et agneaux
vous avez constaté différentes
infractions temps de transport trop long
dont vous avez parlé systems d'abb
revanche défectueux quelles sont les
sanctions prévues par la loi contre
toutes ces bavures alors le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya pas eu à part une
amende
c'est tout ce qu'il ya eu et on peut pas
laisser juste une amende aux camions et
laissé repartir le camion alors
comme je disais tout à l'heure la police
est venue on a arrêté le camion c'était
assez bizarre parce qu'ils ont allumé
les systèmes d'eau tout d'un coup tous
les amis et tous les animaux avait à
boire
alors vous avez 35 heures je n'avais pas
vu sur un des camions ça a été
particulier parce qu'il ya des animaux
qui avait du mal à respirer
il ya eu une inspection police ils ont
regardé les papiers administratifs et
papiers de transport après ils ont
regardé dans le camion quand ils ont vu
qu'il y avait des animaux qui respirait
quasiment plus ils ont appelé le service
vétérinaire qui est venu tout de suite
et on a continué d'inspection avec eux
mais en termes d'infraction à part une
amende c'est tous cas et puis le camion
devait repartir petit restait 5 50 ou
100 km et il fallait qu'ils repartent
pour que les animaux arrivent à
destination
alors justement pour l'instant que des
amendes en terme de sanction vous qu'est
ce que vous souhaiteriez mois déjà
j'aimerais que
on diminue le transport d'animaux
vivants qu'on privilégie l'abattage sur
place et que déjà le temps de pause et
est important les durées transforce est
important et tout ça qu'il faut revoir
ce au niveau du texte et puis il ya une
aberration dans le texte c'est qu'il ya
le temps de transport maritime est
considéré comme un temps de repos avec
les roulis sur les bateaux ce qui s'est
passé dans le canal de suez c'est pas
possible ce soit un temps de repos donc
un autre déplacement dans le cadre de
cette commission c'était à l'abattoir de
blancafort dans le cher en france en fin
d'année dernière cet abattoir avait été
pointé du doigt notamment par
l'association l214 et la préfecture pour
ses pratiques envers les animaux vous y
êtes allé en mars dernier vous étiez
accompagné à l'ordre de l'association de
protection animale mais aussi d'un autre
eurodéputé manuel bompard vous avez
notamment publié ensuite une vidéo sur
votre site où on voit un camion arrivait
avec les volailles
est ce que les choses se sont améliorées
pour les dindes et les dindons l'avenir
de m de cette vidéo
à la suite de cette vidéo je dirais que
non puisque 2 décembre à
au moment où je suis allé sur place avec
manuel bompard on a constaté les mêmes
choses au niveau du transport
c'est-à-dire des caches toujours aussi
petit
les animaux même assis il n'avait pas su
il peut pas se lever et mêmes assises
avait pas de place aux teams les ailes
dépasse et des cages donc non c'était
absolument pas possible
et en plus on n'a pas pu voir l'abattoir
visiter l'abattoir puisque on vous a
refusé l'accès dans l'abattoir on nous a
dit non c'est bon tout étonnant au norme
alors on vous a refusé l'accès en tant
qu'eurodéputé en tant que membre de
cette commission
quels sont vos pouvoirs jusqu'où vous
pouvez aller pour enquêter
par exemple sur sur ce cet abattoir
j'y suis allé en tant que députée
européenne membre de la commission des
transports par une commission des
transports d'animaux vivants j'ai
demandé à rentrer dans l'abattoir pour
voir ce qui ce qui avait été mis aux
normes parce qu'elle est pas mal de
choses qui n'étaient pas aux normes
on nous a refusé l'accès je peux pas
aller au delà de ça
on nous a refusé de rencontrer le
vétérinaire de la ddpp qui étaient sur
place et on vous a dit vous inquiétez
pas tout est aux normes ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on a pu voir et constater c'est les
camions qui arrivent et donc on était à
l'extérieur si on peut pas voir on peut
exactement et sylvain ça que je fais pas
mal de missions sur le terrain pour
essayer malgré deux de certaines choses
autre thème la pêche on veut dont nous
avions déjà reçu dans une europe
donc sur ce thème puisque vous siéger au
sein de la commission pêche du parlement
européen la justice européenne a
confirmé l'interdiction de la pêche
électrique
la cour de justice européenne a rejeté
un recours des pays bas qui voulait
maintenir cette technique
la décision prendra effet à partir de
juillet est-ce que vous pouvez d'abord
nous décrire cette technique de pêche
elle était très utilisée aux pays bas
c'était une pratique courante mais aussi
parce qu'elle est utilisée ailleurs elle
était utilisée aussi en france alors moi
j'espère vivement qu'elle s'arrête au
1er juillet parce que les textes c'est
une interdiction donc il faut pas aller
au delà
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'on a pu octroyer des licences
ou des dérogations 10 ans et ça c'est
pas normal
donc ils n'ont pas obtenu gain de cause
pour l'instant à la technique de pêche
c'est un chalut équipé d'électrodes qui
est mais je dirais un champ
électromagnétique
du coup tout ce qui est est au fond
remonte en surface avec cette onde de
choc on va dire le problème c'est que il
n'ya pas que les poissons qui remontent
il ya tout ce qui est animaux marins en
général il n'y a pas de sélectivité au
niveau des jeunes élevé juvénile c'est
pareil et au sein de la biodiversité
désastreux ouais alors pourquoi est ce
qu'elle est jugée néfaste sur
l'environnement sont donc c'est pour
cette raison cette interdiction de la
pêche et les cris ou c'est une décision
que vous
vous aviez que vous salue et que votre
combat depuis 2006 et un congrès depuis
des années sur l'amendé mandature
précédente c'était yannick jadot qui
s'occupait du combat de la pêche
électrique je continue son combat et je
vais faire en sorte que ce combat ben
s'arrête avec justement l'obtention de
la fin de cette pêche électrique alors
vous militez aussi pour un meilleur
contrôle des pêches en général vous êtes
exprimés en ce sens devant le parlement
le but protéger les populations poisson
mais aussi les inégalités envers les
pêcheurs c'est votre objectif
oui parce que il ya une injustice et une
grande injustice entre la pêche
industrielle et la petite pêche côtière
si on la répartition des quotas ont dit
oui mais c'est les états membres qui
gère des quotas au sein de chaque état
le problème c'est qu'il ya un article 17
qui répartit les quotas sur des critères
environnementaux sociaux qui n'est pas
appliquée et d'ailleurs sur la
problématique du thon elle n'est pas
appliquée notamment par la france quels
sont les moyens aujourd'hui dont on
dispose
l'union européenne dispose pour
contrôler la pêche alors déjà faut faire
pression sur les états membres pour
faire appliquer cet article 17
et puis on a obtenu une victoire ya pas
très longtemps sur le règlement de
contrôle avec les vms
on a des systèmes de vidéosurveillance
sur des zones marines protégées où il ya
un bip qui aimait quand un bateau va sur
une aire marine protégée va pêcher dans
une aire marine pool à la
vidéosurveillance elle est sur les
bateaux dans les ports sur les bateaux
sur les bâtons directement zone europe /
sensations
bonjour sylvie brunet bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé membre de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales du
parlement européen et membre du groupe
renew europe alors avec vous c'est donc
de l'emploi et des conditions de travail
dont nous allons nous intéresser
aujourd'hui avec vous il y a quelques
mois vous avez évoqué un phénomène
croissant celui de la pauvreté des
travailleurs en soulignant que la part
des travailleurs européens exposés au
risque de pauvreté était de 9 4% en 2018
soit plus d'un point par rapport à il ya
dix ans alors est-ce que vous pensez que
la crise sanitaire va accélérer ce
phénomène écoutez malheureusement et
même si dans le plan d'action pour
mettre en oeuvre le socle européen des
droits sociaux
il ya bien inscrire les l'idée de
diminuer le nombre de personnes en
situation de grande pauvreté
malheureusement compte tenu de cette
crise sanitaire tout les alertes heures
sont en place pour dire que hélas le
nombre de personnes en situation de
pauvreté augmente alors on ne serait ce
que le phénomène des jeunes on voit que
sur 2020 le chômage des jeunes a déjà
augmenté de 2 3% dans l'union européenne
en 2020 alors qu on était plutôt sur des
bons signaux et donc tout cela indique
que les plus vulnérables vont
effectivement être plus concernés par
cette crise sanitaire dont on espère
sortir le plus vite possible et que peut
faire l'europe
sur cette question le plan de relance
européen est ce qu'il va pouvoir
atténuer les effets de la crise est-ce
que c'est prévu pour l'heure où il le
plan de relance européen heureusement a
pris en compte ce sujet social nous
sommes d'ailleurs beaucoup intervenu sur
le point on a beaucoup insisté pour dire
attention on peut pas se contenter que
de la relance économique
attention au social et donc notamment
dans le cadre de la négociation
du cadre budgétaire 2010 en 2027 sur le
fse le fonds social européen plus a été
augmentée 3 % vont être dédiés au
minimum là aussi il a fallu beaucoup se
battre à l'aide aux plus démunis
puisque le fonds européen d'aidé aux
plus démunis maintenant fondu dans le
fse plus est dans le cadre de réactiver
ou inquiètent le parti partie du plan de
relance vraiment dédié à
l'accompagnement de la crise et à la
sortie de crise il y a également un
sujet social des fonds dédiés aux plus
jeunes justement sur les plus vénérables
autour de la garantie genèse d'un
investissement dans les compétences pour
que tous les états membres et un minimum
de fonds dédié aussi à la jeunesse
donc ça a été plus en compte d'un plan
de relance plusieurs études ont
également montré que les travailleuses
été plus touchés avait plus souffert de
la crise que les travailleurs est ce que
ce que vous avez également constaté oui
globalement on a eu beaucoup d'études là
dessus les femmes
là aussi c'est malheureusement un
principe simple et plus vulnérables sont
les plus touchés et les femmes sont
souvent dans des situations plus
vulnérables soient en situation de
famille monoparentale soit sur des
secteurs plus exposés comme le soin le
service à la personne ou du coup elles
ont été plus exposés à la maladie à la
pandémie aussi plus de femmes dans des
emplois
ils ont du travail non décent dissimulé
donc pas reconnu officiellement on en a
plus dans le cadre des cartes d'enfants
de l'aide de la garde de personnes âgées
donc du coup qui se sont retrouvés plus
exposés et sans travail mais aussi on a
eu tout les domaines du télétravail
je dis aussi où les femmes ont été plus
affectées par ce qu'elles ont toujours
plus de charges au niveau familial dans
leur notamment en termes de risques
psychosociaux et de conditions de
travail donc coville ou et je ne parle
même pas des violences faites aux femmes
ont chacun sait qu'on a eu une
augmentation 30 % environ des violences
faites aux femmes pendant cette crise
sanitaire
la lutte n'est que pour l'égalité femmes
hommes elle doit être encore plus
renforcé aujourd'hui une fois l'encens
plus loin elle est absolument et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que fort heureusement
nous travaillons sur au moins deux
sujets la directive qui vient d'être
proposée sur la transparence des
salaires pour lutter contre les écarts
salariaux entre les femmes et des hommes
en europe
donc ça ça va être un sujet très
important pour qui plus de transparence
des rémunérations le salaire minimum qui
compte va concerner beaucoup de femmes
aussi dans l'union européenne
et bien évidemment aussi un plan pour
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes
donc plus que jamais bien sûr qu'il faut
renforcer nos actions en europe pour
réduire les écarts et des inégalités et
à leurs autres thèmes les conditions de
travail dans le secteur de l'aviation
qui représente arrêtez moi si je me
trompe près de 6 millions d'emplois
c'est un secteur qui était déjà très
concurrentiel avant la crise et la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui n'a rien arrangé
alors en préparant cette émission j'ai
découvert qu'il existait pour le
personnel navigant et même des pilotes
des contrats de travail différents et
très varié selon les pays
européens et que dans certains cas
certains personnels devaient même payé
pour voler je voudrais que vous nous
dresser un petit peu l'état des lieux de
ce secteur
oui alors c'est vrai que ce secteur
quand on regarde les emplois indirects
c'est près de 9 4 millions d'emplois
dans l'union européenne
bien sûr tout cela en ce moment on le
sait particulièrement affectées mais
malgré des interventions multiples
notamment règlement 2008 qui déjà
demandé à ce qu'il y a un statut du
personnel navigant est donc dans le
secteur de l'aviation
pour toutes ces raisons mais aussi 2015
la commission qui s'est réengagé à ce
qu'il y ait un statut plus uniforme en
europe malgré tout ça on a vu se
multiplier
ce qu'on appelle le pay to fly donc
c'est vraiment payé pour voler ou on se
retrouve quasiment avec des personnels
navigants qui doivent se payer eux mêmes
leur status je puis dire avec des
statuts de travail indépendant dans
certains cas bon pas vraiment justifié
beaucoup de différences d'un pays à
l'autre et ce qui est important c'est la
notion de lieu principal d'activité
c'est ce qu'on doit regarder nous au
niveau européen pour dire de quels
contrats de travail de quelques statues
de travail relève alors on a eu
effectivement ce phénomène avec beaucoup
de jurisprudence les compagnies
aériennes certaines essayant de trouver
de meilleurs statuts possible et en
rendant plus vulnérables ce personnel
navigant voilà donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet effectivement le statut de ces
personnes qui par définition bouffe d'un
pays à l'autre
avec ce fameux pays to fly contre lequel
il faut quand même se battre et vous
donc je te ment tant qu'eurodéputé vous
prenez quoi une harmonisation
oui moi je prône
effectivement une harmonisation une
meilleure définition justement de ce que
je disais le lieu principal d'activité
la base de travail au moins être sur ce
qu'on met dans ce statut en se basant là
dessus quel est le lieu de départ où on
ne passait plus de temps même s'ils ont
des personnels navigants
et puis c'est tout le sujet de l'europe
sociale
et cette fameuse mobilité en ce moment
un peu mise à mal mais qui va repartir
où on ne doit pas voir se multiplier des
statuts très différents d'un pays à
l'autre sinon les entreprises s'en
saisissent et vont aller toujours à
l'endroit où le statut leur est plus
favorable et pas forcément je peux voilà
être plus avantageux et et c'est pas
forcément plus avantageux évidemment
pour les travailleurs qui sont sont plus
en situation de faiblesse
autre secteur la livraison l'entreprise
de livraison de repas just hits
concurrents du mérite et de des livres
ou veut embaucher 4500 livreur en d'ici
la fin de l'année
mais pour vous c'est une opération de
communication où ça va dans le bon sens
c'est une bonne chose je ne sais pas si
nos opérations de communication pour
être très honnête
après c'est leur choix statutaire c'est
tout le débat en ce moment sur les
livreurs puisque moi je je suis
rapporteur sur la les conditions de
travail des travailleurs des plateformes
sur un rapport d'initiative et qu'on va
avoir sûrement une directive
on a tout un débat dans l'union
européenne et même en france sur le
statut qu'ils doivent avoir
est ce que ce sont des vrais
travailleurs indépendants ou pas alors
dans un certain nombre de cas et de
critères notamment pour la livraison on
va peut-être pouvoir analyser qui sont
en fait salariés maintenant est ce qu'il
faut le systématiser
on va voir si on arrive à des bons
critères just hits on les cite souvent
d'abord j'attends de voir combien de
personnes y vont exactement recruter et
puis est-ce que ça va convenir ou pas on
verra bien mais il est vrai que dans un
certain nombre de situations ses défauts
travailleurs indépendants donc à partir
du moment où ils sont pas bien rémunéré
par rapport à leur travail pas protégés
en termes de maladie d'accident du
travail devrait être plutôt en relations
de travail salarié et donc c'est vrai
que ça va plutôt dans le bon sens si on
arrive à ça alors vous vous n'êtes pas
naturellement contre les plateformes les
entrepreneurs c'est juste que vous
voulez éviter certaines dérives donc il
ya un besoin d'encadrer quelles sont les
pistes aujourd'hui sur lesquels vous
travaillez pour justement cet
encadrement alors les pistes sur
lesquelles on travaille c'est d'abord de
regarder quel est le minimum de
protection sociale et de droit qui
doivent avoir ça c'est la première chose
importante
deuxièmement pour que tout ça s'améliore
était bien ce minimum qu'on soit
travailleurs indépendants ou qu'on soit
salarié
on doit avoir cette protection il ya la
négociation collective et donc dans les
pistes il faut ouvrir la possibilité de
discuter de ses conditions de travail
aux travailleurs indépendants
ce que les règles de la concurrence en
union européenne ne permettent pas de
faire parce que travailler en
indépendant même un chauffeur dans vtc
il a assimilé à une entreprise
donc il peut pas discuter avec les
autres sur ses conditions de travail les
conditions fise que vont lui donner les
plateformes et donc ça déjà il faut
qu'on y remédie d'ailleurs en france on
est en train de le faire ils
troisièmement une meilleure protection
vis-à-vis des logiciels des algorithmes
parce que quelquefois il ya des
changements dans les gammes de rim sur
leur temps de travail sur leurs
conditions de travail sont pas vraiment
informés ils savent pas à quoi
s'attendre
comment ça va interagir sur leurs
activités et ça c'est vraiment un vrai
problème mais définir cette protection
sociale qui doivent tous avoir et déjà
ça va dans le sens des travaux
antérieurs du conseil et de l'europe de
manière générale pas besoin de passeport
ni de valises pour voyager je vous
invite à présent un voyage culinaire
soon europe voyage
moi je vais vous présenter les ruines
des roulades l on te dit à irin soul
adele ou il s'agit donc des escalades de
boeuf
avec une farce la moutarde oignons
cornichons et du lard enroulée qui sera
cuit en braisé servi avec des spätzle
maison en beurre et du chou rouge en
allemagne et c'est simple vous allez
chez le boucher
vous demandez dire ou laden vous auriez
des tranches troupe préfète
on est en france dont quand ça sera un
peu compliqué de demander aux bouchers
français de nous couper les escalopes de
boeuf
donc c'est ce qu'on a fait là on a une
fois pris du pal rond on en a des
copines une belle escalopes mais on va
aussi faire l'essai avec des rampes
stake qu'on a légèrement aplatie
légèrement puisque faut pas non plus
détruire la structure du boeuf donc les
rides narula des noms vallée tartiner
avec la moutarde
c'est la moutarde raymonde du taf et
diane qui moins fort qui la dijonnaise
elle mais papa aussi sucré que
l'américaine non plus où on peut être
bien généreux
ensuite on va mettre et des oignons
moi j'aime bien les oignons donc je suis
généreux évidemment vous pouvez
désormais être moi aussi vous pouvez
aussi mettre les rendez moi j'aime bien
les dix petite brume ensuite des
guignols bourquel des cornichons rien à
voir avec les petits cornichons de deux
ans en france bien croquants le
cornichon à helmand la gravure du gour
que donc là j'ai mis les cornichons en
longueur de l'escalope et on va
l'enrôler avec 100 la voilà nous avons
donc enrôlé dans vos laden puis on les a
ficelé maintenant une fois qu'ils sont
en compétition est ficelé on va les
saisir on va mettre le beurre dans dans
la grande dans la marmite et on va
attendre que leur iphone
on va faire attention qu'adviendrait se
passe quand on travaille à vue dix gaz
donc ça peut aller très très vite
et en valeur les les mettre dedans pour
les saisir
la sas et civils on va baisser le feu
déjà
et maintenant
on va sortir neurologue qui ont
également saisi et maintenant a commencé
à mettre toutes nos légumes
je les ai quand même épluché pour la
taille de la casserole on va couper
légèrement mais là les carottes et les
oignons c'est bon en entier et lézignan
et maintenant vas y ajouter de l'ail du
temps du laurier et du romarin
on va mettre de cuillère à café de miel
un chouïa de vin blanc
une manne muscat un peu tape rica du
poivre du sel est un pilier au vin rouge
et pour finir on met de l'eau puisque et
en veut à la fin quand même beaucoup de
choses parce qu'ils nous font le coup
tous là on a fait un très joli fond avec
beaucoup de saveurs beaucoup
d'ingrédients un bon petit faon qu'on va
maintenant à langer à l'eau depuis on va
remettre les roulades aidants et puis
faire éric pendant 1h30 2h à feu doux
dans notre marmite
je vous souhaite un très bon a pity avec
avec un des plats typiques allemand le
plus connu apprécié par par mois ma
grand mère mais aussi par un guy
lamarque end zone europe s'est terminée
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site
internet et notre application radio
sensations mais également sur tv 78
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
très bonne soirée sonne rod sûr
sensation